[Music]
[Applause]
David Pollock used to be on uh college
game day and former NFL player an
All-American at Georgia and uh kind
enough to join us on the program all
right uh let me start with Oregon in
Washington some of the um game time
decisions late game decisions there with
Dan Lanning how do you explain his
philosophy I don't know I don't have an
explanation for you Dan I'm sitting
there going like what are we doing I
mean I I I get it and listen Oregan and
and Dan laning like they they want to be
aggressive right like that's their
mindset and aggressive aggressive
aggressive I think there's a fine line
between aggressive and Reckless and um
and I think that was a little bit
Reckless when you're at that at Midfield
you know around that area I don't know
man and listen I I don't think they had
a lot of confidence to stop Michael
pennick Jr and and probably rightfully
so and you saw he scored and and then
they had time to go down and try to kick
a field goal to tie it and maybe that
was the thought process that you weren't
going to do it but man oh man and listen
these analytics Dan they drive me nuts I
mean it's just strange to watch like
you're sitting there watch there was
there was another game I'm watching the
Falcons game yesterday and you're going
they're down by 14 and they score with
14 minutes left in the fourth quarter
and they go for two and I'm
like what are we doing like I I know
that little sheet of paper says if they
kick a field goal and then we do this
and if we get it I just I mean I think
sometimes we out think it man I just I
think I'm I'm punting the football
trying to down him inside the one get a
few sacks Rush him a little bit make
something happen um it was it was an
interesting decision by by Oregon what
do you take away from Washington and
Michael penck
Jr I I tell you what man I I I knew
coming into the game Oregon was going to
have a better run game I thought it
would be easier for him um I thought
Oregon's up front would win a lot more
but do you see the ball placement that
he plays with I mean he just first of
all the Lefty just looks fun it looks
good coming out like it just it looks
sweet um but the ball placement the the
weapons out wide at wide receiver I just
I think they're going to be a tough out
and listen if you look across college
football I don't think Washington's
defense is Elite but again are we are we
comparing them to everybody else where
every I I can poke holes in everybody
there's not a single team in this in
this in this playoff picture this year
that I can go that's a dominant team on
both sides of the football so when you
have him and you have those weapons and
you have an offense um I think that I I
think that they're going to have a shot
to do what they want listen the schedule
sets up great too if you haven't been to
Washington by the way that's a tough
place to play man like they are they are
a Ravid fan base like it is very in the
South feeli to it like it's nuts and and
and they've got a great schedule at home
so if you think Washington's a purple
flash in the pan you're wrong how does
USC not have a
defense um I mean okay so your your
defensive philosophy leaves a lot to be
questioned um you know they believe in
stunting up front you know the majority
of the time they believe in playing deep
coverage um you know the way they've
recruited obviously you know you can
tell that a lot of the the bullets go to
the other side of the football which is
which is fine but a system that is um
you know listen if you want to be honest
it's just not the system that builds a
lot of you don't see a lot of toughness
I don't see a lot of physicality let's
put it that way on both sides of the
line of scrimmage and we've seen over
the years whether you spread it out and
and put more emphasis on quarterbacks
and speed and and the outside in the in
the end if I got guys that can win in
the trenches I can change the numbers
advantage that that everybody likes to
play with and I just don't see a lot of
you know blocking for Caleb Williams up
front was a struggle the defensive line
stopping the run and and getting a
consistent pass rush was a struggle so
the line David is it talent that they're
lacking or is it philosophy that they're
lacking I I think that I I don't think
they have a lot of depth of talent UPF
front um but I do think the philosophy
needs to continue to be tweaked so I
will say that that I think I think they
could do more with what they have
talking to David Pollock um Georgia
looks vulnerable like it feels like
there's not great team so you uh
handicap your alma
mater well Brock Bowers being banged up
changes it too um so let's see what what
comes out about him but I would be
surprised if he's back in the next
couple weeks and um they're in offensive
team I think they're a team that you're
going to have to depend on Carson Beck
who's listen he he's a flamethrower like
that dude's got an arm he's got Poise
he's got weapons with makoni and you see
rat Thomas starting to come on you know
another a transfer from Mississippi
state so I think I think they're good
enough to score with anybody um stopping
people is going to continue to be a
challenge you saw it with Vanderbilt
again I mean the defense is if you turn
on a game the last two years and you
watch George's defense and you turn it
on now you're like what happened and
here's the thing you don't have runs
like that like that all of those guys
that you saw during those those two-year
run They're all playing on Sundays if
you turn the tape on like you start
watching Sundays like oh yeah I remember
that guy that guy played defens of
Georgia that guy defense at Georgia I
mean all 11 of the defensive starters
for the first national championship they
all got drafted so I mean it's just it's
going to look different but if you look
at the schedule Miss is going to be a
problem a running quarterback with a
system that can also run the football
throw the football a little bit more but
again that's at home uh Missouri is the
is one of is their next toughest game
that's at home so it is a tough place to
go to walk into with that crowd that
noise that atmosphere it's tough for
anybody to go in there and win Colorado
is up big on Stanford a lot of people
probably turned that off it was a Friday
night how big a story is Colorado now in
college
football um I I think the people that
wanted to line up and and take shots at
Dion It's a big story for them now like
they're they're excited about that but
man that was a colossal failure the
other night I mean that was you know
you're up 29 to nothing on an anemic
offense in Stanford um you know you
built your you built your team around a
Travis Hunter type guy who got beat all
night and just got beat all and listen
the thing I I would say watching that is
okay if if I'm Colorado it what point do
I go I'm up 29 let's run the football
let's eat some clock let's not play fast
like it didn't make a lot of sense to me
but you're not expecting Stanford to
come back though I mean I I guess In
fairness to Dion and Colorado they want
to continue to you know put up big
numbers there let everybody see what
they're doing there I don't think they
were thinking you know Stanford could
come back we got to run the clock well
and then you look up and you say see
what had happened was I mean so like and
that's the thing man do do you want
style points sure if if you want style
points Let It Rip but man I I want to
win football games and when you lose to
it when you have this and you're
trending and you beat TCU and obviously
that's not like a big win now we see
that TCU is not a great football team
but when you start to to build momentum
here's the thing it's easy to build
momentum in the beginning of something
like a lot of coaches come in and build
momentum and build energy the hardest
thing to do is sustain it and when you
start losing to one and four Stanford
and now you now the ship looks a little
bit different and and and creating that
tital wave of recruiting and creating
the energy and the buzz man it's just
it's hard to continue to do you only
kind of get that one shot at it and I
think this kind of takes them takes him
down a notch and and puts a little chin
in the armor good to talk to you as
always David thank you for joining us
great to talk to you Dan say Bob David
Pollock former Georgia Bulldog and well
always a Georgia Bulldog and used to be
with college game day